thank you for that power you wouldn't
lie to me if you really play your cards
right yeah our next guest may join us
whoa who is it another woman you love
almost as much as me who is it
ladies and gentlemen Jules Oh
hi guys
happy birthday Robin good to see you too
see you Joe thank you for that great
entry you guys in the suckiest crowd
I've ever been around
Wayne whatever I have to thank you a lot
of people know my story from your show
actually you guys gave me an opportunity
actually talk about my life and it's an
unusual thing to have that opportunity
so a lot of you might know I was really
lucky I got to when I was 16 I had this
dream that I got to open up for Bob
Dylan and five years later actually got
to open up for Bob Dylan which was like
a dream come true except that there was
more to my dream in my dream Bob Dylan
totally came on to me you know and so I
was really worried that like the rest of
my dream was going to come true and so I
got a nun tour and his tour manager was
like welcome to the road Dylan doesn't
watch the opening act he doesn't listen
to him I was like great after four
nights he was like Dylan actually wants
to meet you he's requesting your
presence in his dressing room and I was
like I know but you can't not meet Bob
Dylan so I went downstairs and he was
really great he really mentored me when
I was about 20 or 21 and I mentor him
and I blew him and he read me books for
while it happened so that was cool and
then Neil Young took me out on the road
and really mentored me had a big
influence on me but in my entire career
I have to say there's really been one
songwriter that has affected my
songwriting especially my lyric writing
a very prolific songwriter the fact that
he wrote this in sixth grade is really I
think a testament to what a prodigy
what a prodigy he was
so it's a pleasure to sing this song
that that my hero wrote see Robin you
guys have to help me sing the core it
must be true merry complain and I'll
give you a silver silver nickel
be number one like me all careful is me
Civic nickel some golden axe all your
here
those change silver
nickel
another one like me and all I care for
is
silver nipples and golden night on here
are Devils
nickels
there will be there will be there will
be now will be and will be and will be
next
how about that jewel silver nickels and
golden doffing I wrote a hit I wrote
that in sixth grade it doesn't sound
like what you wrote
am I not sure is that a good song
Jewelers etiquette song you're not that
song speaks for itself I mean the
amazing empathy that you had for the
plight of the working woman well they
had to trade their self-esteem for money
it was really feminism paving the way it
taught me a lot about being a woman
jewel really understands my music and
Who I am as a person
I think she's reading in it's a great
way of saying no I can't tell you how
honored I am that you just did that song
because it redeems me I told Robin I am
a great songwriter and she doesn't
believe it thank you true what made you
like in sixth grade talk about giving a
woman money for sex I have I have no
idea I was just sure that was my future
no have you ever paid a woman percent I
have never done that I would just be
humiliated I'd rather just sit home and
stare at a wall than do its it drooled
see now you'd love me even more well
that's a jewel everybody how much she's
a blast from Howard's past